[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est Henry
Gueno bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation Henry Guenot
vous êtes encien conseiller spécial de
Nicolas Sarkozy auteur de ce livre à la
7e fois les murailles tombèrent c'est
aux éditions du Rocher on a évidemment
envie d'avoir votre regard sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment sur l'actualité elle
est riche Henry Guen a commencé par
cette loi immigration qui occupe une
grande partie de l'actualité et une
majorité des Français qui pensent que le
texte permettrait un meilleur contrôle
de notre immigration ils sont 67 % à le
dire est-ce que vous en faites partie
non non et je je trouve abusif de dire
que 67 % des Français pensent que ce
texte permettrait de contrôler
l'immigration parce que la la plupart
des Français n'ont pas lu le texte vous
savez quand on veut savoir quelle est la
vie des des des français sur un texte de
ce genre alors on le soumet en
référendum et il y a il y a
préalablement un débat qui éclaire les
Français et après il peuvent choisir en
toute connaissance de cause en réalité
ce que disent les Français dans les
sondages c'est qu'ils veulent que les
flux migratoires soient maîtrisés voilà
donc tout ce qui leur est présenté comme
possibilité de mieux maîtriser les flux
migratoires est approuvé par l'immense
majorité des Français mais je pense que
même plus de 67 % de gens qui souhaitent
la maîtrise des flux migratoires à juste
titre comment vous vous l'expliquez que
autant de français justement veuillent
plus de sévérité euh sur la politique
migratoire mais d'abord il faut revenons
au fond des choses euh il n'y a pas de
nation et pas de démocratie sans
frontière voilà c'est-à-dire un
frontière qui définit un espace un
espace de droit de solidarité euh euh de
de culture commune de valeurs communes
donc prè premièrement maîtriser ces
frontières est un est un besoin
fondamental des peuples qui ont une
conscience de peuple qui ont conscience
de former un peuple et de former une
nation euh et puis depuis une des
décennies euh on ne maîtrise plus rien
alors j'allais dire certaine façon
délibérément on sait délibérément
euh privé de de tous les instruments qui
permettent de de contrôler tant bien que
mal mais de contrôler ses ses frontières
alors il y a bien sûr derrière il y a
aussi des enjeux géopolitiques majeurs
que nous maîtrisons moins mais que dont
nous n'avons pas tenu compte non plus
euh un exemple on a voulu faire à une
époque l'Union pour la Méditerranée qui
permettrait peut-être aussi non
seulement de gérer des questions commune
d'environnement questions économiques
mais aussi de gérer en commun les flux
migratoires euh qui traverse la
Méditerranée ou qui se déroule autour du
pourtour de la Méditerranée bon tout ça
a été a été balayé marginalisé nom pour
la Méditerranée existe toujours mais
elle n'a elle n'a pratiquement plus de
plus de contenu euh bon donc euh et puis
on s'est on s'est on s'est privé de tous
les instruments juridiques qui font
encore une fois que nous avons des
frontières et que nous pouvons
démocratiquement
décider de ce que de ce que nous voulons
accueillir et dans quelles conditions
voilà et puis enfin on a refusé on a
refusé l'assimilation he cétait c'est
brusquement il y a eu un basculement
idéologique l'idéologie dominante a dit
l'assimilation ça ça n'est pas bien
l'assimilation j'entends par là euh non
pas l'obligation pour ceux qui arrivent
d'abandonner leur histoire personnelle
familiale leur culture d'origine mais
mais l'obligation pour eux de prendre en
partage une une histoire commune avec le
le pays dans lequel ils veulent
s'installer et vivre une culture une
façon de vivre des meœurs euh une
politesse enfin toutes sortes de choses
qui font une civilité particulière
autour desquelles on peut construire une
une nation et même une société voilà
donc on a abandonné tout ça et dernière
étape on a
euh détruit presque détruit en tout cas
ravagé la société on a fait la
mondialisation n'importe comment on a
fait l'Europe n'importe
comment on a laissé s'effondré le non
seulement
l'économie la cohésion sociale mais
aussi
l'école et tout tout ce qui nous faisait
une une société commune et solide on a
une société fracturée une société
fracturée malade et qui plusé travaillé
par la haine de soi n'a rien à offrir
enfin n'a pas les moyens d'accueillir et
elle n'a rien à offrir comme idéal à ce
à ceux qui arrivent à partager à ce qui
arrivent voilà donc tout ça mi bout
àabout fait que on peut comprendre que
les Français souhaitent que très vite on
se non pas l'immigration zéro on arrive
à l'immigration zéro ça n'a pas de sens
mais qu'on reprenne une la maîtrise de
des flux migratoires beaucoup de Ch
c'est pas propre que pour la France he
c'est pas propre à la France c'est
propre à tous les pays de l'Occident
tous compris de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique il y a il y a beaucoup de
choses dans dans ce que vous nous dites
vous nous parlez des des outils
juridiques il il y a une décision qui a
beaucoup fait parler ces dernières
heures c'est le le Conseil d'État qui a
épinglé Gérald haranin le ministre de
l'intérieur parce qu'il avait expulsé un
oubec qui était soupçonné de proximité
avec la mouvance djihadiste ce que lui
contexte et et et le le Conseil d'État
demande à Gérald armanin de le faire
revenir disant que ça contrevient à la à
la liberté de de mouvement qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette décision parce que
ça fait partie des juridiques dont vous
parlez moi je suis mararve d'être
critique vis-à-vis des décisions des
juridictions françaises mais il faut
faut pas caricaturé donc le juge des
référés celui qui statue en urgence du
Conseil d'État a rendu cette décision à
la suite d'une décision de la de
la de de la Commission européenne des
droits de l'homme voilà donc qui a qui a
près duquel le l'ousbec en question
avait fait uncours et la la la CD DH a
demandé le retour
donc en constatant que on avait violé
les les droits de de ce monsieur parce
que on l'avait renvoyé dans un pays où
il était en danger et donc le le le
Conseil le conseilétat constatant enfin
en tout cas le juge des référés qui ne
juge pas au fond hein mais constatant
que on avait on avait délibérément violé
les les droits de ce monsieur selon la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme a
demandé le le le tour de de l'ousbec
alors faut quand même regarder les les
les choses en face d'abord il a n'a pas
il na même pas décidé
d'astreinte il a il s'est contenté de
d'enjoindre à l'état de réparer en
disant il y a eu une erreur une faute
juridique enfin manifeste he euh les
droits ont été manifestement violés donc
bah vous devez
réparer ça c'est c'était logique et et
et normal bon de la part du Conseil
d'État dans l'état actuel de notre de
notre droit maintenant il faut bien voir
une chose donc ça nous renvoie un débat
sur à la fois le le le conseilat et la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme al je rappelle que les États se
sont engagés la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ne juge pas à la place
de nos juridictions hein elle rend des
décisions qu' appartient quand c'est le
cas à nos juridictions de de d'appliquer
ou d'introduire dans leur jurisprudence
par exemple si la Cour Européenne des
des droit de l'homme décide qu'un procès
est inéquitable quelqu'un a étaé jugé de
façon inéquitable
elle elle ne refait pas le procès mais
il existe en droit français une
disposition qui dit que le le requérant
peut à ce moment-là demander une une
révision de son procès bien que tous les
recours a été épuisés une commission de
révision se réunit et puis si elle
trouve que la position de la Cour
européene de droits de l'homme est
justifiée à ce moment-là on réouvre un
procès mais la Cour ne juge la cour Eure
de droit de l'homme ne juge pas enfin ne
juge pas ne refais pas les procès voilà
les é en ranche se sont engagés quand
ils étaient parties prenantes au
contentieux à appliquer les décisions de
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
mais la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme n'a aucun moyen de forcer les
les de forcer les États et il arrive que
les États n'appliquent pas pour des
raisons qui leur sont propres euh voyez
si le si donc là il faudrait ne pas
appliquer bah c'est ce qui va sans doute
se passer peut pas forcer l'État à le à
le reprendre si le Conseil d'État avait
annulé l'arrêté d'expulsion avant qu'il
soit et que le le le gouvernement se
soitessus ça poserait un problème très
grave de d'État de droit pour le coup
moi je suis pas un maniaque de de un
fétichiste de l'État de droit tel qu'on
le considère aujourd'hui mais il y a
quand même qu'il faut quand même qu'il y
a un ordre juridique mais est-ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin juridiquement hier
soir les républicains ont écrit une
lettre à Emmanuel Macron en disant je
les cite il faut engager une ambitieuse
révision constitutionnelle pour mieux
armer juridiquement notre nation face au
défi migratoire elle est nécessaire
cette révision pour alors oui
c'està-dire que la la loi immigration ne
servira qu' quasiment à rien tout le
monde le sait c'est ça qui qui est très
délétaire au fond pour la démocratie y
compris Gérald haranin qui répète à
longueur de journée que la lo
immigration ent en
vigueur au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
a une direction des libertés publiques
elle est elle est dirigée toujours par
un conseiller d'État la direction de
liberté publique sait très bien même si
ça pouvait échapper à à tous les autres
elle sait très bien que cette loi ne
servira pas à grand-chose pratiquement
rien parce que dans ce domaine dans le
domaine du droit des étrangers
aujourd'hui c'est le juge qui fait la
loi en réalité et pas le législateur
mais pour des raisons que le
législateur le le le le pouvoir
politique a organisé depuis des
décennies donc il faut changer ça pour
changer ça il faut effectivement se
tourner en priorité vers la constitution
ou en préalable la Constitution euh donc
a raison sur le fait que le préalable
c'est la réforme constitutionnelle
maintenant le projet qui a été qui a été
rédigé par par mes amis de de LR ne
répond pas à la situation c'est-à-dire
que en fait il est un peu comme la loi
c'est un faux semblant quand on le lit
on voit bien que on va pas au bout de
cette de cette idée et qu'on fait
semblant pourquoi alors il faudrait fait
semblant parce que alors d'abord parce
qu'on réintroduit enfin dit il faut
élargir l'article 11 chance de l'article
11 pour pouvoir faire des référendum sur
ces sujets oui tout le monde est
d'accord mais on
on on dit que dans dans ce projet que il
va falloir enfin on va le Conseil
constitutionnel va pouir donner un avis
sur la constitutionnalité des projets
soumis au peuple ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas écrit dans
la Constitution sauf pour le référendum
d'initiative partagé donc là on redonne
vous savez quand on donne un avis même
non
non non enfin qui n'a qui n'a pas de de
qui n'a un effet que consultatif hein ça
finit par devenir ça finit par devenir
un avis contraignant c'est c'est une
mécanique juridique implacable donc il
faut pas réintroduire le Conseil
constitutionnel dans cette affaire donc
ça ça me paraît invalider déjà une enfin
rendre la situation peut-être encore
pire qu'aujourd'hui et deuxièmement dire
on va on va se on va on va créer une
procédure qui permet de d'obtenir des
dérogations euh quand l'intérêt
l'intérêt vitau qui est une primuté du
droit national sur le droit européen
dans C cas V l'intérêt vital du btanger
ou quand il y a il y a atteinte à la ce
que le Conseil constitutionnel appelle
l'identité constitutionnelle de la
France c'est laisser au juges euh la la
la liberté totale d'apprécier si c'est
le cas ou pas donc en vérité euh la
seule si on veut rétablir une forme de
primauté de la loi nationale euh il faut
revenir à l'état antérieur du droit qui
qui prévalait en France selon les
jurisprudences d'ailleurs de la Cour de
cassation et du Conseil d'État pour la
Cour de cassation jusqu'en 75 et pour le
Conseil d'État jusqu'en 89 euh qui qui
euh qui était qui reposait sur le
principe que c'était la dernière ex
ession de la volonté du législateur qui
s'imposait donc si la loi était
postérieure au traité malgré la
rédaction de l'article 55 c'était la loi
qui l' emporté si le traité était
postérieur à la loi c'est le traité qui
l' emporté là il y a pas de débat il n'y
aurait pas de
débat sur interprétation puisque c'est
une ce serait une question de date si on
vous vous suit ça veut dire que il faut
le réviser pararticle 11 de la
Constitution ce qui est un autre parce
que sinon ça ne marchera jamais comme de
Gaul en 62 ce qui est un autre un autre
débat politique majeur puisque un tas de
gens considèrent que deg a violé la
Constitution en 62 en utilisant
l'article 11 pour réviser la
Constitution mais sinon on n' sortira
pas voilà donc il faut juste estce que
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui les juges
ont trop de poids ont trop de pouvoir
dans notre pays alors c'est c'est ça
veut dire que d'abord les juges peuvent
du fait de la hiérarchie ce qu'on
appelle la hiérarchie des normes
c'est-à-dire savoir quel est le est-ce
que ce sont les conventions
internationales droit européen le la et
qui l'emporte sur no national dans tous
les cas donc il peuvent écarter la loi
française hein moi quand j'étais jeune
on me disait le juge ne juge pas le
législateur et bien de fait il est
devenu juge de législateur et
deuxièmement je trouve mais ça c'est un
autre c'est un débat encore plus large
que la subjectivité a a beaucoup trop
envahi le champ du judiciaire et le
champ du droit public voilà c'est-à-dire
que évidemment il y a toujours une part
de subjectivité dans le dans le rendu de
la justice parce que c'est la justice
est humaine mais là on a on a dépassé
toutes les limites mais subjectivité
c'est quoi c'est un obist la
politisation des jug mais c'est
subjectivité ou c'est politisation non
c'est pas c'est pas seulement
politisation ça c'est une petite partie
du problème ça ça rentre un sous c'est
un sous-ensemble de cette histoire mais
quand vous dites par exemple le juge
juge de la proportionnalité de la de la
mesure il juge par exemple de la
proportionnalité de la réponse du
policier au au à celui qui le menace
c'est parfaitement subjectif de comment
vous voulez juger bon donc c'est c'est
si vous si vous en abusez si vous ne
vous mettez pas de limite et c'est le
cas et bien tout devient subjectif ce
qui vient de se passer dans le procès
dans le procès contre Monsieur Dupont
moriti le montre bien c'est-à-dire que
la prise illégale d'intérêt est devenue
parfaitement subjectif puisquelle
concerne aujourd'hui non seulement
l'intérêt matériel qui est tangible qui
est lui est mesurable mais aussi
l'intérêt parfaitement subjectif
l'intérêt par exemple
affectif bon l'intérêt moral
donc ça laisse un champ de en fait
d'arbitraire au sein de l'État de droit
couvert par l'État de droit sur lequel
il nous faut il nous faut réfléchir et
on pourrait appliquer ça à la justice
des mineurs à enfin en fait à tout notre
droit publ et et judiciaire voilà et ça
c'est un sujet plus vaste si vous jugez
par exemple de la de ce qui'est une vie
familial normale bah c'est parfaitement
subjectif donc vous pouvez faire toutes
les lois que vous voulez à la fin pour
expulser quelqu'un s'il fait des recours
bah le Conseil d'État jugera en fonction
de la vie familiale normale c'est déjà
arrivé selon son point de vue sur la S
politique de la semaine quel regard
avez-vous porté sur cette alliance qui
s'est constitué entre laanup le
rassemblement national et et une grande
partie deslr pour voter cette notion de
proet alors d'abord je trouve ce débat
surréaliste je trouve surréaliste qu'on
accorde autant de qu'on F en accorder
autant d'importance à des textes dont il
est probable que puisque le juge
finalement décidera probable que dans 3
ans on constatera qu'ils n'ont pas eu
deseffits majeurs et tout le monde dira
ils nous ont menti une fois de plus
voilà donc c'est très délétaire mais je
trouve aussi que le débat autour de
cette de de de ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine euh à propos de cette loi est
surréaliste parce que Ben d'abord il y a
pas d'alliance il y a ça que que des
gens qui ont des opinions
contradictoires pour des raisons
différentes votent pour un projet ou
contre un projet mais c'est le propre de
la démocratie quand quelqu'un est élu il
va pas voir dans les urnes euh pour
quelle raison les gens ont ont voté pour
lui d'ailleurs ça n'a pas monsieur
Macron ne sait pas réveillé matin en
disant ah bah c'est embêtant parce qu'il
y a quand même beaucoup de gens dans
Lyonne euh qui n'auraient pas dû voter
ensemble bon pareil pour n'importe quel
député pour n'importe quel élu pour
n'importe quel maire c'est la démocratie
à forciuie pour un référendum donc voilà
c'est la démocratie il y a rien à il y a
rien à redire ils ont voté ils ont voté
contre quelque chose dont ils ne
voulaient pas pour des raisons
différentes et même contraire bon mais
ça c'est c'est c'est le c'est la loi de
la démocratie donc il y a pas d'alliance
ils ont pas ils ont pas conclu un accord
de gouvernement ils ont pas bon donc il
y a rien il y a rien à dire il y a rien
à dire là-dessus il y a ni à condamner
euh ni à à triompher enfin ce voilà
c'est un débat pour rien mais tout ça
tout ça abîme la démocratie tout ça
parce que comme tout ça sont des faux
semblants tout ça sont des des des des
des des sujets qui des débats
qui compris des républicains mais mais
tout le monde parce que enfin les
républicains ils ont leur part de
responsabilité moindre que le que le
gouvernement mais mais comme tout le
monde c'est c'est à partir du moment où
vous vous vous vous ils ont ils ont pas
ils ont calcul politique qui est
parfaitement rationnel et qui est
parfaitement raisonnable donc c'est pas
sur le calcul politique évidemment il
préfèrent qu'on discute sur leur projet
que sur le projet des autres c'est
normal et c'est très bien ils ont donc
remporté une victoire politique mais la
question est de savoir si on a remporté
une victoire sur la maîtrise des flux de
de l'immigration qui va permettre de
restaurer un peu de crédibilité
démocratique et politique dans dans
notre pays et là la le leur tort à eux
c'est de donner trop d'importance et de
faire comme si ce ce ce texte de loi
était décisif même dans sa version
sénatoriale voilà est-ce que un échec de
ce projet alors vous vous nous dites
qu'il apporterait pas grand-chose voir
rien au contrôle des des flux
migratoires mais est-ce que dans
l'opinion publique un échec de ce texte
entraînerait une montrée montée du
rassemblement
national je je je suis pas capable de
juger ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
s'il n'a pas d'effet il entraînera
encore plus de crise démocratique et
peut-être bien bien bien autre chose que
la montée du du rassemblement national
parce que c'est faut faut arrêter d'être
obsédé par ça la question est de savoir
ce que va devenir notre société si elle
va sombrer dans un dans un B de violence
terrible ou pas ce que va devenir notre
démocratie si elle va être de plus en
plus contestée ou pas et ça va bien
au-delà de la questionà disparaître bah
écoutez ça c'est déjà arrivé dans
l'histoire tout peut nous arriver c'est
c'est ENF c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit
ce livre aussi c'est que c'est c'est que
il faut que nous arrêtions de penser que
ce qui est arrivé aux générations
précédente ne peut plus nous arriver oui
la guerre civile la fin de la la le en
tout cas le le la mise de côté un temps
de la de la démocratie la guerre de
religion la guerre tout court le le la
la violence généralisée oui cela peut
nous arriver aller demander aux
Israéliens
euh si ce qui est arrivé pouvait si vous
aviez demandé quelques jours avant
personne n'aurait penser que ça pouvait
arriver commencé par les jeunes gens qui
dans qui qui qui faisaient des raves
parties à 4 km de Gaza c'était
impensable voilà et bien c'est arrivé la
guerre de 14 au fortes de l'Europe ça ne
pouvait pas arriver ça pouvait pas la
guerre ne pouvait pas arriver et la
guerre de tranchée ne pouvait pas
arriver non plus enfin les ça fait des
années qu'on nous explique qu'on a plus
besoin de char de canon d'avion que tout
ça n'arrivera plus c'est arrivé la
pandémie ça pouvait pas nous arriver
c'était réservé à des pays en
développement ça nous est arrivé et nous
n'étions pas prêts bon donc je je oui ça
peut ça peut nous arriver et c'est quand
nous pensons c'est quand nous commençons
à penser que ça ne peut plus nous
arriver que le danger montte le danger
lequel celui que ce qu'il y a de pire
dans l'homme la violence intrinsèque de
l'homme il y a l'homme le meilleur et le
pire le pire ce qui est maintenu dans
l'homme par la civilisation par la
civilité par la culture par l'éducation
par les institutions ne rencontrent plus
de barrière et sortent de l'homme et
dévorent tout sur son passage voilà le
grand risque d'quel nous nous approchons
enfin faut est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il y a
une naïveté chez les Français de croire
que le leur nation ne disparaî pas que
leur civilisation disparaîtra pas que
leur mode de vie ne disparaîtra pas
alors il commence à y avoir une
angoisse voilà et la la question une
angoisse qui monte he je veux dire alors
il y a des gens qui se rassurent
toujoursens ça peut pas arriver il y
ceux qui souhaitent que ça arrive
d'abord va les laisser de côté mais mais
ils sont nombreux he il fautut ceux qui
souhaitent que ça arrive et puis après
ceux qui pensent que ça va ça ne va pas
ça ne va pas arriver mais il y a eu
quand même une angoisse C terrible alors
on vous dit pour vous rassurer oui mais
tout ça statistiquement c'est pas
significatif mais vous savez il y a pas
besoin qu'il ait beaucoup d'actes de de
violence physique pour que ça devienne
un un problème pour tout le monde et que
ça crée de l'insécurité parce que parce
que si c'est ça c'est c'est l'histoire
du du jeune hugbyman qui seit assassiné
dans un petit
village si les français commence à
penser qui ce qui n'est pas faux au vu
des événements que ça peut peut leur
arriver n'importe où n'importe quand à
n'importe qui il y a pas n'y a pas
besoin qu'il en ait 10 par jour
comprenez c'est juste ce qu'on pourrait
appeler en mathématique l'c probabilité
c'està-dire que où que vous trouviez
vous tuez un vous décapitez un prof et
tous les profs se disent que ça peut
leur arriver vous en décapitez un
deuxième encore plus et tout ça dans des
endroits souvent improbabl voilà et si
demain vous en avez un autre dans dans
un lycée en pleine ruralité bien on
saura que vraiment partout ça ça peut
arriver ça n'est pas irrationnel mais
est-ce que ce drame de crpol dont vous
parlez a mis en lumière de France selon
vous alors moi je je me refuse
absolument à à faire ce diagnostic de de
France ou de deux peuples je pense que
c'est un risque qui est devant nous
c'est un risque don dont nous n'avons
pas pris conscience depuis des années
que nous fabriquons nous sommes en train
de fabriquer peut-être cette situation
mais qu'il faut tout faire pour qu'elle
ne se produise pas si on pense qu'elle
est là alors il y a plus de solution
nous finirons dans l'affrontement voilà
c'est parce que deux peuples de France
sur un même territoire deux
civilisations face à face sur un même
territoire on sait très bien ce que ça
donne toujours dans l'histoire toujours
c'est derrière il y a la nature humaine
regardez en israëlle je veux dire ça
donne un affrontement et un affrontement
qui devient vite un affrontement
sanglant voilà et donc ça vous en parle
dans votre livre mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il avoir un risque de
guerre civile dans not il y a un risque
encore une fois et il y a trois catégor
gens ceux qui pensent ça peut pas
arriver ils sont fous ceux qui ou
aveugle en tout cas ceux qui pensent que
ça doit arriver ceux qui le souhaitent
absolument hein et ils sont bah ils
jouent avec le feu ils sont criminels
c'est-à-dire
que ils espèrent l'affrontement voilà
donc B et puis il y a ceux don moi je
par qui pensent que il y a un impératif
moral catégorique à tout faire pour que
ça n'arrive pas encore faut-il être
conscient que ça peut arriver si si vous
en êtes pas des somes d'ambul c'est un
mot notamment que que vous employez
quels sont les remparts aujourd'hui pour
éviter que ça arrive mais les remparts
c'est tout ce qu'on a construit
déconstruit affaibli donc on parlait du
juridique on continue on continue à
faire semblant on continue à ne pas pas
vouloir débattre et regarder en face les
changements radicaux qu'il nous faut
faire pour nous adapter à la situation
regarder les phénomènes des bandes par
exemple donc en 71 on avait fait parce
qu'on arrivrivait plus à à
à a maîtriser la la violence des groupes
de casseurs la violence bon on avait
fait la loi anticasseur c'est pas les
fascistes qui l'avaient fait hein
c'était jacquandelmas qui était qui
était premier ministre vous imaginez bon
la gauche arrivant en pouvoir la défit
elle introduisait une une forme de
responsabilité collective hein je
m'explique si si euh si si bande entoure
une voiture de police bloque les les
portières et que l'un d'entre eux jette
un cockail molotop sur la voiture pour
faire griller les policiers dans ce
qu'on a déjà ce qu'on a déjà vu c'est
pas que celui qui jette le cocktail
Molotof qui est coupable il y a une
culpabilité collective il faut que nous
réfléchissions dans les circonstances de
notre époque où nous nous trouvons dans
la face à la nature de la violence à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés à
peut-être à introduire dans notre code
introduire dans notre code pénal une
part de responsabilité collective par
rapport au phénomène des bandes bande de
de je enfin quand des enfants de 12 ans
13 ans 14 ans s'entretuent à coup de
barre de fer il y a peut-être des
questions à se poser
quand quand des des des des bandes
attaquent la la police de la façon dont
je viens de dire il y a des questions à
se poser on voit bien que ce phénomène
se développe bon et bien il faut que
nous nous regardions cette situation en
face et que nous réfléchissions
posément à la à la modification des
principes sur certains sujets en tout
cas de notre droit pénal qui lui
privilégie à juste titre
dans le l'individualisation de la peine
et de la responsabilité surtout mais il
a des situations où il faut il faut
changer parce que si nous ne le faisons
pas alors nous aurons les tribus les
bandes la guerre des tribus la guerre
des bandes ça ça c'est c'est c'est ce
qu'il faut éviter vous savez la justice
la police elles sont là pour éviter le
cercle de la vengeance et on voit
poindre le cercle de la vengeance le
cycle de
l'autodéfense tout ça c'est
extraordinairement dangereux donc il y a
il y a tout à refaire il faut il faut
faut rétablir les institutions réfléchir
à notre à notre droit refaire l'école
c'est c'est c'est un désastre alors même
si on fait des annonces aujourd'hui
c'est très profond bon il faut réfléchir
faut faut se demander il va falloir du
temps gabrielal dit qu'il va falloir 10
ans avec son falloir temps mais si si si
on le fait jamais si on l'avait fait il
y a 10 ans on en serait peut-être sorti
un dernier mot sur l'un européenne
puisque on en parlait au début de cette
émission l'Union européenne qui s'est
accordé hier pour ouvrir les les
négociations d'adhésion à l'Ukraine et à
la Moldavie est-ce que c'est une bonne
décision pour vous d'élargir encore
l'Union européenne mais non enfin on
narrive déjà pas à à gérer l'union de
façon correcte on va introduire des des
pays al il faudra beaucoup de temps hein
B ça c'est clair mais des des des pays
dont le niveau de corruption le niveau
de le niveau de vie euh m pour l'Ukraine
il fallait pas envoyer ce signal mais je
sais pas quel signal on envoie est-ce
que est-ce que le signal qu'on veut
envoyer c'est que il n'y a pas de
solution négociée possible entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine si c'est ça on se
condamne à une guerre peut-être
intermittence éternel enfin je veux dire
dont l'Europe va être la victime est-ce
qu'on peut réfléchir je sais bien que
les responsables d'aujourd'hui seront
plus là demain euh mais peut-être qu'il
pourrait penser à demain voilà c'est et
de toute façon l'Europe toute seule ne
va pas arriver à résoudre ce problème
mais si on crée toutes les conditions
pour ne ne pas le rés pour qu'il soit
pour qu'il devienne insoluble euh ça
enfin on prend une on joue avec le feu
on prend une responsabilité considérable
et d'autr part encore une fois la la
l'absorption matérielle de de de de ces
pays va poser un problème l'Europe est
déjà affaiblie déjà fracturée déjà
divisée qui enfin où va-t-on trouver qui
à qui va-t-on demander de faire l'effort
énorme de de d'intégrer progressivement
ces ces pays vous voyez la situation
sociale de l'Europe vous vous la ENF
est-ce qu'on voit est-ce qu'on voit le
retour de de la fracture sociale qui est
en train de miner toutes les sociétés
européennes et d'amener des bon pour
l'instant on en est au populisme mais
encore une fois faisons bien attention
que après les populismes on n'est pas
bien pire voilà donc est-ce qu'on peut
se se s'interroger sur la les les les
intérêts vitaux de l'Europe et la
fragilité de nos sociétés avant de
prendre des décisions à l'emporte-pièce
uniquement pour satisfaire
une notre notre sentiment d'être le camp
du Bien euh ah si les Américains
laissent tomber vous croyez que l'Europe
tout seule va arriver à résoudre ce
problème elle va se mettre dans des
difficultés et elle va voilà ça ça va
contribuer à a bloqué toute solution je
je voilà c'est pas ça n'est pas le
moment euh et et d'autre part je
peut-être qu'il faut réfléchir à ce que
peut être la neutralisation de de de
l'Ukraine après tout on a sauvé la on a
redonné la démocratie la souveraineté à
à la à l'Autriche pendant la guerre
froide avec la neutralisation euh on a
enfin la neutralisation a permis à la
Finlande pendant des des décennies de
survivre souveraine même à côté de
Staline peut-être que c'est une solution
à laquelle il faut songer et qu'avait
proposé en son temps Henri Kissinger et
même et même
brinski en tout cas c'est là on se la
pose plus voilà on se pose plus de
questions
et voil on a un espèce de jeu de rôle
moralisateur mais qui n'est pas de la
morale en fait parce que la morale ça
consiste pas compliquer la situation à
nous amener dans des impasses tragiques
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité je rappelle le titre de votre
livre à la 7è fois les murailles tomber
CX édition du merci de nous avoir
apporté votre regard on passe au club
des territoires